[Music]
harvey's catastrophic flooding is an all
too familiar scene for victims of
hurricane katrina many people were
flooded out 12 years ago were forced to
evacuate once again houston was
nicknamed new orleans of the west after
taking in so many evacuees back in 2005
and many chose just to stay in that city
now they may be forced to move again
adriana diaz is at the k bailey
hutchinson convention center that's in
dallas which will house evacuees from
houston adriana good morning
good morning the convention center is
prepared to welcome 5 000 evacuees from
houston and there's a good chance that
for some they're going through this
ordeal for a second time in a second
city
pretty much the same thing you know
it's pretty much the same thing dominic
robinson said it's like deja vu once
again checking into a shelter after
leaving home on a rescue boat it's what
he did when he was living in new orleans
during hurricane katrina an experience
that taught him life-changing lessons
survival survival and just staying
patient and just waiting to just kind of
ride it out
that's all you can pretty much do with
these hurricanes is pretty much sit
tight and ride it out
the images of the past few days have
drawn comparisons to the 2005 disaster
that left much of new orleans submerged
the similarities weren't lost on new
orleans mayor mitch landrieu as the
anniversary of katrina hovers above us i
think all of us remember
you know all too well where we were at
that time
and all of those images are
frighteningly familiar to all of us
12 years ago more than a million people
abandoned their homes many boarding
buses to houston and taking shelter
inside the astrodome houston reportedly
welcomed as many as a quarter of a
million evacuees and the city estimates
40 thousand never moved back how much
more uneasy could you feel
right now in the city of new orleans
other than
saying there but for the grace of god go
i in houston you only think oh something
like that will only happen once
but it's happening again for rachel
allen who lost her house in new orleans
to katrina my family we pretty much made
houston home
she's riding out the storm with her
husband and one-year-old son this time
her house is safe even as the flood
swallows another city around her it's
devastating to watch
on the news and even though everything
you see is just terrible you find
yourself not being able to pull away
from the tv just a very similar
experience this time around as well
so far losses from hurricane katrina far
surpassed those from harvey 1800 people
lost their lives in hurricane katrina
which was the costliest natural disaster
in u.s history but for those who lost
everything in houston it'll be a long
road to recovery margaret adriana thank
you yeah in the words of that great
philosopher chris rock you want to say
that ain't right but you go through it
once and then it happens to you again
when you think that would only happen to
me once in my lifetime truly
unbelievable i think so too i think so
too